now we turn to politics in the upcoming
election our updated CBS News
Battleground tracker shows the
Republicans are holding their advantage
in the race to control the House of
Representatives with three weeks to go
we estimate Republicans have 224 seats
to the Democrats 211 enough to take back
the majority CBS News elections and
surveys director Anthony salvanto joins
us right now how you doing Anthony I'm
all right how are you I'm good so it
seems like we were just talking about
the Democrats chipping away at the
Republicans
um lead in the house what happened well
we were talking about that and then it
ran into this look at worsening views of
the economy Nate look at this two-thirds
of people say it is getting worse and
let me show you why one of the ways
people interact with the economy is gas
prices you're paying more you're seeing
those big signs up back in August there
was some optimism majority said well
okay they're going down but look at this
now 63 percent say gas prices are going
up in their area so I asked people okay
well let's turn to politics here who are
you blamed for this what's the reason
well look there's more folks now who say
that Democratic policies have harmed the
economy then helped it it's not the only
reason they see for this but they're
reasoning out of results right they're
filling a pinch parties in power okay
must be doing something wrong and then
by contrast they think well Republican
policies more likely would help again
they're not in power so that's how they
think yeah okay so the topic of abortion
has been tied to Democrats gains
um where does that stand now well it has
helped the Democrats and it's still
important Democrats but take a look at
this chart what issues are very
important and look at these big numbers
over here the economy right popping up
at 80
70s inflation so that's really swamping
it right now compared to others and even
those abortion doesn't show up here now
watch this if you look at the splits
between people who say abortion is very
important Democrats are winning them
still are but Democrats are losing
Republicans winning those who say they
economies vary okay so let's talk about
voter turnout when it comes to
enthusiasm in this election yeah look
this might be the most important thing
let me show you each breaks people say
they'll definitely vote look at this
much smaller numbers under 30. they're
not as engaged with politics they're
feeling like the economy is not working
for them so they're kind of standing
back and not getting as involved but
older people are that's a big difference
because the younger people are part of
the democratic base right they don't
show up hurts Democrats chances younger
people get out there and vote it's
important Anthony savanto we appreciate
you thanks Nate